WELL GOOD MORNING HAPPY NEW YEAR
TO ALL AND WELCOME TO THIS
COMMITTEE'S FIRST HEARING OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
OF ASSEMBLY PURRS.
COMMITTEE REVOCABLE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OFFERS WELL LIKED
TO SAY WE'VE BEEN INFORMED THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALLEN WILL NOW BE
JOINING US TODAY. AND WITH THAT
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR DOCKET
FOR TODAY.
AND WITHOUT A SECURE STEPS OR
.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM SERVER
FIRST WENT UP TO HIS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOROUGH.
IS
AB TEN TWENTY THREE.
GO AHEAD YOU WHEN YOU'RE READY.
A THIRD GOVERNOR.
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN.
AS CALIFORNIANS WERE FAMILIAR
WOULD FAVOR SIX IS BEING RONALD
REAGAN DAY.
IT'S A SPECIAL DAY TO CELEBRATE
THE LIFE OF RONALD REAGAN
SCHOOLS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
FAMILIARIZE PUPILS WITH THE
CONTRIBUTIONS HE MADE TO THE
STATE.
AS A STATE HOLIDAY THE SAME'S
OBSERVATIONS WOULD CONTINUE AS A
STATE HOLIDAY. ALSO LYING STATE
EMPLOYEES TO OBSERVE RONALD
REAGAN DAY IN LIEU OF ANY OTHER
STATE HOLIDAY THAT HERE SHE
CHOOSE. THIS INCLUDES FLOATING
PERSONAL HOLIDAYS.
GOVERNMENTAL SERVICES WOULD NOT
BE IMPACTED US ALL STATE
AGENCIES WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ENSURE ENOUGH STATE EMPLOYEES
ARE ON DUTY.
TO CONDUCT BUSINESS
ABOUT I JUST ON A PERSONAL NOTE.
SOME OF WHO CAME THE AGE IN THE
SEVENTIES AND. ARE GROWING UP
WITH GAS LINES.
.
AND HOSTAGES IN IRAN YOU KNOW I
SORT OF.
CAME AWARE OF.
.
AMERICANS ISSUES.
DURING THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS A
IMPORTANT FACTOR IN MY LIFE
ACTUALLY SERVED IN THE MILITARY
WHILE HE WAS PRESIDENT. AND THEN
I HAD THE HONOR OF MEETING HIM.
AFTER HIS SERVICE IN HIS LOS
ANGELES OUR OFFICE AND WAS ONE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF MY LIFE.
AB TEN TWENTY THREE WOULD
INCLUDE CALIFORNIA IN AND
SEVERAL STATES.
THAT INCLUDE TEXAS THEY
RECOGNIZE AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH
AS PRESIDENT LYNDON B. JOHNSON
DAY AND MISSOURI RECOGNIZES MAY
EIGHTH. AS PRESIDENT HARRY S.
TRUMAN DAY.
ESTABLISHING FEBRUARY SIX AS A
LEGAL HOLIDAY CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
FITTING TO SET ASIDE THESE THIS
DAY TO HONOR SUCH AN INDIVIDUAL
PAY TRIBUTES THE CONTRIBUTION
REAGAN MADE TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF ASTRAEA
VOTE.
THANK YOUS R. ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRODE PROJECTED
CLOSE ON YOUR.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR A
CONVENING THIS COMMITTEE JUST TO
HEAR THE SIDE OF HIS CHAIR AND
ASK ABOUT THE.
HE WITH THAT IS THERE A MOTION.
SECOND.
THE MOTION AND SECOND.
WITHOUT THE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANKS FOR
BRINGING US SO.
HERE TODAY FOR YOUR BILL AND.
WITHOUT A JUST HAVE COME I LIKE
TO SAY.
.
AFTER RESEARCH WITH MY STUFF
JUST SEEM LIKE THIS BILL IS NOT
REALLY WORKABLE.
AND THE REASONS WHY IF STATE
AGENCIES ARE CLOSED AND
EMPLOYERS ARE OFTEN IN EXISTING
STATE HOLIDAY BUT AN EMPLOYEE
CHOOSES TO OBSERVE RONALD REAGAN
DAY INSTEAD. OF WHETHER ONE OF
THE OTHER STATE HOLIDAYS HOW
WOULD THIS WORK WITH THEIR
EMPLOYER FOR CLOTHES AT THE
EDGES CAN CAUSE MORE CONFUSION.
TO THE MATTER WITHOUT.
AND WITHOUT A WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
SORT THAT SECRETARY LIKE KALRA.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ
NOBODY.
ALLEN.
BRO FIVE.
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
O'DONNELL.
WE'LL PUT THE THUMB BELONG
KHtNG I KNOW WHERE MEMBERS
ABOUT JEWISH THAT'S WITH THAT
DUNCAN EXECUTIVE CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU
YEP
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
BACK UP DO YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THE.
THE BILL.
BONTA.
SO THAT THE MOTION FAILS. TO AYE
AYES AND FOR KNOWS THANK YOU
WITHOUT.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED